[Música]
eu sempre falo que quando apresenta em
palestra assim eu queria que minha mãe
eu visse porque eu não acho nada disso
sem essa coisa a mais tudo bem eu vou
aceitar
é eu entendo meu nervosismo pela minha
bexiga eu acho assim talvez no intestino
também é porque fazer triatlo numa época
que toda vez que chegava a largada eu
ficava assim eu perdia o
contingenciamento ou entrava em
continência urinária foi o 14 vezes no
banheiro agora mas enfim então ela
apresentou eu sou o beto madalosso eu
vou eu tenho dois restaurantes o
empresário e eu quero falar um pouco
vocês sobre esse assunto hoje de manhã
sobre o clima organizacional acho que
uma das coisas que está acontecendo na
minha vida que eu tenho aprendido
bastante é uma coisa que eu tenho uma
consciência diferente está mudando a
maneira de ver a minha forma de pensar
que o empresário é eu sempre uma coisa
que eu digo algum tempo eu eu acho que
só vai fazer sentido eu tenho um
restaurante em uma empresa até o dia que
os funcionários vale pra mim eu tô
chegando trabalhar aí olhava pra mim foi
assim que bom gritar aqui que bom que
ele chegou que não se veio o seu viajar
e ficar um tempo fora as pessoas que
trabalham comigo sentir falta de mim
quando eu chegava a cimpor que bom se
esqueceu que voltou que vamos aqui com a
gente é muito triste um lugar que a
gente trabalha que as pessoas olham para
a gente é assim q merda o chefe chegou
né é e não é nenhuma hipocrisia isso eu
já passei por isso na época nos anos meu
pai que o fábio neri também tem gente
tem alguns restaurantes mas eu trabalho
há muito tempo e quando eu era novo
começou a sumir tinha o gerente que
é não tinha muita vida com o funcionário
o clima era horrível eu ia trabalhar eu
tinha medo de trabalhar eu tinha uma
sensação horrível ea chegado não me dava
bem com as pessoas trabalhavam lá dentro
enfim uma outra história mas tive que
mudar aquilo e tal e depois que abriu os
meus restaurantes o grupo faz em 2011 o
primeiro eu sempre tive em mente assim
eu precisava ter um grande trabalho que
fosse legal é é difícil manter um bom
trabalho legal sem desafiador porque não
é sempre bom empresário tem um hábito de
estranho né mas muito e muito é
espontâneo de reclamar de tudo
a empresária tem uma mania horrível que
já disse a vítima do sistema quando ele
não é vítima
é difícil não é também é fácil a
brincadeira mas é de difícil pagar
imposto é difícil ver né é o governo
fazendo fazendo merda de fizer a
mão-de-obra complicados ensina fala
repete os caras fazem errado isso tudo é
complicado mas essa é a nossa missão e
lidar com isso saber olhar para isso
entender que são pessoas que não tiveram
as vezes a mesma formação que a gente
não tem a mesma visão enfim não vão
acompanhar toda a gente pensa então já
sabe lidar com isso e é não tem também o
primeiro restaurante equipe era muito
diversas e até a gente montar um clima
organizacional entendível demora um bom
tempo mas eu digo que hoje estou bem
satisfeito assim bem feliz com a equipe
que trabalha comigo e e cada vez mais
até assim aprendendo muito com isso
hoje tem pessoas de tantas em de todos
os tipos
tem homem mulher de todas as idades
então tem por exemplo a menina que
acabou de sair da faculdade se for
mantido em chefe de cozinha cozinheiro
tem uma senhora que não tem estudo
nenhum é tem imigrantes haitianos e
tenho 67 anos trabalhando com a gente
hoje vou contar quatro histórias rápidas
e conseguiu desse negócio 18 minutos 15
será quanto mas vou tentar noite falando
45 horas de provocação assim eu vou
começar pela história sete anos até um
pouco simples assim eles apareceram
trabalharem contratou o filme fala de
dois ouviu macchio nixon são 27 anos
eles vieram da noite e deixar a família
logo depois o terreno do terremoto no
haiti e é o filme que deixou a esposa e
uma filha
e à equipe toda começou a se mobilizar
para fazer uma vaquinha para trazer a
esposa do do filme pra brasil nessa
juntar um dinheiro passou alguns meses o
que demorou a chutar mas talvez mais
tempo é de repente ela chegou a
trabalhar com a gente hoje já está bom
tempo acho que estamos três anos com
gente andrizzi ela depois de um tempo
trouxe uma filha que ficou lá também
ficou com a avó trouxe pra cá hoje tem
outra filha que nasceu no brasil
aí tem unique munique deixou a esposa
grávida então não viu a filha dele
nascer veio pra cá né busca de uma vida
melhor e tal e com o tempo a equipe
também se mobilizou neve começaram a
juntar dinheiro e tal
já na vaquinha trouxeram é a esposa dele
a filha dele que deve fazer um ano que
está aqui eu até não tenho slide que eu
não sei os slides ou muito ruim e
tecnologia eu na verdade eu não sabia
que era ted é eu vivo dando palestras em
escolas de gastronomia tal eu falava
numa palestra sábado quando você é saber
até di - ministrado comité de miltinho
sem falar no ted não está nervoso né
falando num troço assim de bom tudo bem
eu chegar aqui beta microfone fala uma
coisa e vai embora nem notar mas enfim
que bom que não pede e enfiei então
nesses caras hoje tem uma vida
construída aqui por conta de um trabalho
de equipe até que acontece naturalmente
ser muito interessante isso os dois
estados um pouco mais especiais um pouco
diferentes e eu sempre quis contratar
uma pessoa com um com deficiência
crescimento assim na pequena televisão
xávega porto como é legal ter a poder
ter alguém assim que legal quem faz isso
é bacana uma causa nobre e tal mas nunca
fui atrás assim afinal o empresário
critica o empresário empresário essa
cabeça assim que não é nada dá tempo não
consigo não é prioridade isso prioridade
da lucro
o resto nazária mas eu queria fazer isso
e eu tinha acabado de voltar de viagem
eu fiquei um tempo parado e agora
recentemente fui fazer um curso na
itália voltei 2017 e estava se arrumando
o restaurante várias coisas para ver
porque né tinha que resolver o problema
financeiro e crise econômica essas
coisas todas é custo
costurar com estas coisas assim é mexer
na gestão estava cheio de coisas na
cabeça fervendo e estava um dia até
dirigindo uma ligação uma moça falou
assim beto foi com muito trabalho eu
acho legal que o trabalho só que eu
queria ter de apresentar um uma proposta
eu faço um trabalho de imagem treinar
empresas para receber pessoas com
deficiência
eu queria jogar o telefone pela janela é
desgraça sai porque não recebo a nossa
nunca vejo a ignorância do empresário
nunca recebo ninguém com deficiência que
não importa se o time vencer o povo não
é 5 lido com isso não tem diferença
claro é só não posso pagar outra
pensamento empresa não posso pagar
porque tudo cortando custos e tal não
quer cobrar nada
eu quero fazer isso quero sempre ajudar
o trabalho faço isso pra você não sei
quanto custaria isso r$250 ramo rita
vergonha né não sabia companheiro e não
pelo amor de deus não tomou café o que
faz questão de pagar está enfim a gente
marcou uma reunião a gente sentou junto
e ela começou a explicar sobre sobre
essa solidez e treinamento
no meio da conversa foi assim como é que
seria pra contratar uma pessoa se faz se
eu quiser conta da pessoa com
deficiência eu faço faço trabalho também
enfrentam vou pensar nisso falou sobre
essa vaga é é um custo mais alto e
estamos bem não vamos fazer se vão fazer
trabalho e eu achei a gente abriu a vaga
nessa gente se encontrou algumas vezes
amigos a vaga
eu falei vai chover gente deve ter um
público aí né que têm interesse nisso
ninguém observada não apareceu ninguém
eu achei que no primeiro dia parecendo
mais um dia dos dias de uma semana um
mês ou mesmo meses e ninguém foi meio
que esquecido aquilo que acho que vamos
conseguir a gente conversando ela
desanimou também e tal eu vou cortar um
pouco da história do povo vota nela
porque vou começar com o outro motorista
do modo uma sessão situação semelhante
no restaurante meu dia-a-dia enfim nessa
mesma época e tem um menino trabalha com
a gente há muito tempo d'alessandro
sobre teto assim num divertido se não
fala com ninguém e se convença não
responde e o cara trabalha na louça ele
super dedicado assim ele tem um de lavar
a louça assim parece um robô assim uma
máquina trabalhando
mesmo passou de beijo eu chego no
momento pela porta dos fundos do
restaurante e é o primeiro cara que eu
vejo tava lavando louça né eu só eu sou
aquele cara que dá oi assim empurrando o
escândalo da ideia beleza ea mania sei
lá eu acho legal as pessoas não é todo
mundo que gosta então chegava nele
primeiro cara que eu via da enr e beleza
o cara olhava assim uma cara de bravo
pra mim eu falo de cachaça no campo
número oito netos dia seguinte saiu
ilesa
em uma dessas da ideia beleza o cara
virou pra mim e me empurrou assim da
encosta em mim e falou não encosta em
mim vou estar louco meu povo tanto vem
aqui cara né porque nervoso assim e tal
sair de perto que tudo aqui a fazer é
mandar embora lógico mas quer ir embora
amanhã engraçado
aí eu pensei de novo empresário
cansei um pouco coisa coisa que dê
errado acontecer mas eu pensei um pouco
aí é ele não tem nada a ver o cara não
gosta encoste nele não posso fazer isso
deixa o cara limpo eu tenho que mudar no
meu ponto de vista
na semana seguinte uma reunião com a
equipe e contei isso falei que a equipe
sinta uma equipe gerencial toda
quarta-feira junto né eu falei olha cada
um chef de cozinha junto sempre está
comigo há muitos anos mas 10
esse carro né fidalgo e gostoso pra ele
quase bateu contra um pouco disso tem o
chefe ou sem carta difícil trabalhar com
ele porque assim volte 69 meia noite no
horário de pico no restaurante que o
karaté e vai embora não fala com ninguém
a some daqui né e não fala nada de
seguinte que vêm trabalhar nele ele não
comenta a gente pergunta não falar nada
nem sequer se sabe disso tá eu falei ele
falou que era mandar embora não por mim
mas se quiser fazer isso o cara da
equipe que faz o que quiser
tá bom passou com este tempo com isso
nem passou poucos dias assim foi uma
moça tomou salah comecei a conversar com
ela e ela da associação das pessoas com
autismo começou a me contar que vai ter
um cara que trabalha aqui ele tem ele
tem esse comportamento também se fala
mais sobre isso assim não falei faz isso
ele tem de ter essa atitude contra essas
atitudes para ela ele vem de bicicleta
professor antes ao lado do campo
cumprido
para ele ele faz exatamente o caminho do
ônibus ele em vez de parar no
restaurante e vai até o centro
é como se fosse um terminal de onde
volta pro santo bicicleta não fosse esse
cara de autismo
ele tem muito certo em último a primeira
coisa que eu fiz uma equipe de novo foi
olha não pode mandar embora ele
dificilmente ele tem autismo ele vai
jogar vou trabalhar não pode ser daqui é
eu sei que é difícil lidar com ele né
não pode também tolerar tudo se for
impossível entender de gente pode
demiti-lo mas é mais se esforçar para
isso ele surgiu quase uma frase se um
lema nós que assim pessoas especiais
merecem uma atenção especial foi tão
legal isso sim foi tão legal essa essa
mudança de consciência minha com o
empresário da equipe como um todo que
logo depois disso veio a natal tem um
amigo secreto é e presente a 50 reais
é aquela coisa da meia na cueca celas e
de seu novo cd não tem mais é eo exame
de uma bicicleta e um chefe quando leu
aquilo ano na planilha de pedidos ele
veio falar comigo você encara o campeão
disse cleto e eu vou dar significado
para ele a gente vai juntar a galera de
novo nós vamos fazer uma vaquinha que no
restaurante vai começar a ficar com ele
juntamos r$1800 alguma coisa assim
completa super legal assim no dia no dia
da entrega da bicicleta e ele nem teve
reação assim olhou aquilo então enfim é
uma mudança de consciência completa
assim divisão do negócio e hoje todo
mundo entende eu volto agora o corte
volta da história da da contratação com
a com a desde ano então ela me liga um
dia falou assim beto aparecer um
candidato aqui ele é um menino com
síndrome de down tarde vamos conversar
então e eu como eu tinha um pouco de
receio de conversar com pessoas com
zumbido não sabe cortar se não sabe se
estava ou está um exame de raio-x
brincavam não tinha uma um apartamento
assim é estranho e ele também o
fernandinho tem agora uma celebridade da
internet ele começou a começou a
trabalhar também
tímido por fechado em maio logo no
começo e consegui ficar muito amigo
assim muito íntimo roma uma química
assim da amizade muito legal e super
carinhoso assim o cara chega mostrando
todos os dias hoje é aniversário dele
inclusive ele quer sair gols nas dez
vezes é l chega no restaurante bar
escritório dal pra todo mundo novo ao
time leva um presentinho no final do dia
ele se despede dele já tinha o telefone
então tátil duas horas depois me ligavam
roberto carlos que se quer
não tô com saudades cara por um é não é
demais a gente realmente não cria uma
amizade assim uma relação tão forte
gente ele chama de pai eu chamo de filho
a coisa louca um pouco fora até do da
questão profissional mas em que acontece
assim é amigo dos amigos livros meus
amigos direto combinam coisa e tal
se fosse fazer uma conta nessa o salário
que que é pago eo resultado que dá na
prática da função é não teria não teria
justificativa porque claro ele trabalha
não desempenha função no nível regular
vive escondido ele fica no banheiro e
neve de mata trabalho fica ele quer
fazer outras coisas que não é muito
ficar o dia inteiro trabalhando é então
não teria isso agora porque traz isso
pra gente de maneira é intangível que é
a transformação traz para a equipe é
toda nossa equipe hoje convive com isso
ajudam ele uma maneira colaborativa ele
quer servir mesa então leva leva a taça
na mesa pessoal tem que ficar
acompanhando entendendo que ele quer
fazer ele tal é muito legal assim porque
isso reflete muito uma transformação
nossa pra mim mesmo pessoalmente me
transformou muito vai ter porque eu
falei eu não sabia muito como lidar e
tal então e para o cliente também tem
sensibilidade de perceber isso é bacana
quando chega um cliente é porque às
vezes a gente chega e vai entregar fish
na porta do carro no pé dele mas pudera
né
o pessoal tá entendendo
é mas enfim eu não trouxe não trouxe
aqui a apresentação mas eu fiz ontem
mexendo com o tema eu falei porque vou
falar amanhã então eu eu fiz um hashtag
em algumas postagens de umas 15 postais
20 talvez que mostra um pouco da
história de uma estranha que é que eu
fiz um hashtag beto madalosso ted
achando engraçado ted né
nessa história do ted do meu tempo beto
madalosso tej eu vou contando um pouco
disso assim tem umas fotos ou contas a
relação com a equipe está bacana mas
para fechar é eu acho que assim o papel
de empresário
não é uma coisa tão nobre tão bem vista
assim apesar de ser um guerreiro mesmo
na disputa o empresário é um guerreiro
do brasil é por que é tão difícil
entender tal tem esse lado mas uma coisa
assim tão nobre mas sim tem sim nas mãos
e acho que o empresário tem sido o papel
que pode ser muito nobre arte momento de
ver o mundo um pouco além das paredes
nosso negócio é fazer um fazer um
negócio um restaurante no meu caso seria
um produto bom serviço bom competir a
lhe fazer e dá resultado é pagar imposto
não fica nessa é difícil eu acho que aí
já tem muito mérito a quem faz isso para
quem tem coragem de prender colocar o
dinheiro à risca e tal
é isso talvez tenha um sentido até um
sentido interessantíssimas e tem muito
mais sentido quando a gente começa a
perceber o nosso é nossa conjuntura
espacial social onde está inserida a
vizinhança o que a gente pode cobrar com
isso e no sentido de escolher o que
coloca na mesa de quem compra nessa
decisão de quem compra se
autoalimentando uma cadeia produtiva que
eu mantenho um cara lá na horta dele que
ele mantém a família né no no campo ou
se eu estou destinando o lixo
corretamente eu tô mandando eu estou
comprando canudo por exemplo usando
muita garrafa plástica esse tipo de
coisa ou se eu tô trabalhando com
questões inclusivas é com pessoas com
deficiência esse tipo de coisa eu sou na
verdade um um cara que estou começando
quase mil se eu estou começando a ter
uma consciência sobre o todo é dar
trabalho dá muito mais trabalho por uma
empresa que olha para tudo isso é porque
existe uma dedicação que eu contei para
vocês mas é muito mais gratificante eu
acho que nós empresários que o
empresário é tem essa essa grande
oportunidade de ter uma empresa e por
deus a empresa para transformar o mundo
num mundo melhor é não ser um cara está
ativista um cara esporte mas também um
cara que constrói e transforma é isso
[Aplausos]